we have a number of webinars going on
please check back for other webinars
that might be of interest to you finally
the materials the powerpoint i'm going
to be showing you are going to be
available there's a link at the very
bottom of the screen where you can get
those materials as well as any answers
to questions that we don't have time to
get to today but if you've asked
questions will certainly try and answer
those and put those up with the
materials a bit later alright so I'm
going to go ahead and get started this
should be about a 10 or 15 minute
presentations today and then what kind
of go from there so we have some changes
that are coming up with the sequence
databases and this is a first webinar we
have a few other announcements that have
come out about this but we're starting
to try to do some outreach about these
changes so that you have time to adjust
to what's going to be happening so the
first thing I'll try and talk about is
what's changing what's going on and the
short answer to that question is that
we're phasing out a kind of identifier
called a GI number and I'll talk more
about what those are in a couple of
minutes that's the next topic what they
are a little bit of a review of what
kind of identifier is that we use for
the sequence databases and why those
changes are happening and when they'll
happen and then the fourth topic perhaps
more interesting what's going to break
if you have a piece of software or a
service what will break as a result of
these changes what won't break and we'll
talk briefly about that as well as some
additional service changes that we
anticipate that will be coming up in the
next weeks and months that are related
to these changes GI numbers so what is
changing so we are beginning to phase
out the usage of the GI number which has
been a sequence identifier use in the
sequence databases for many many years
the one thing to remember about this is
that existing GI numbers records that
already have a GI number those GI
numbers will remain indefinitely all
right so we're not deleting GI numbers
from data they will be able to be used
for retrieving those sequences that have
them already but the real issue is that
in CB I will not be assigning GI numbers
to all new sequences that are being
submitted and over time it will
eventually happen that we will not
assign GI numbers at all anymore that's
going to be a gradual process and it
only will affect new sequences what's
happening soon in September is that we
will no longer show GI numbers on flat
file record views and fast a record used
by default so those GI number simply
will not be present in those data
formats the GI numbers will still be
present in the data record but will not
be visible in the flat file and fast day
formats in March of 2017 you will not be
able to see flat file or fast a formats
with GI numbers at all so we get into
September 2016 they will not be by
default but you will still be able to
get these records with GI numbers in
them and we'll have more about that as
we go along but coming in March 2017 you
won't be able to see the GI numbers at
all so you have about seven months of
leeway to prepare yourself for the fact
that you will no longer be able to get
the GI numbers out of flat files or fast
day so I want to take a brief moment to
show you the original announcement that
came out about this in March of this
year there's a link to it here what I'm
going to do is just switch over to a web
browser to the article itself this
article is on the NCBI news page it's
the feature article on the NCBI news
site just the www ncbi nlm nih gov /
news you can see it there i'm not going
to read through the whole article but i
do want to show you in the article
there's a couple of examples that kind
of make the point so this is part of a
typical nucleotide record in the new
core database what you'll see is the to
identify errs that you see now the GI
number and the accession number and you
also see these for the protein product
in the feature table down here the
accession number for the protein and the
GI number for the protein what will be
happening is that those GI number simply
will be gone right they will not be
shown in the records you'll simply see
the accession you'll simply see the
accession for the protein ID there will
not be a GI number present a similar
kind of thing will happen for the
protein
records again right now in a protein
record you will see the accession number
and the GI of the same line in the
future the GI number will not be there
similarly in fast a formatted records
currently the death line of the fast day
or the title line of the fast day has a
sikh ID identifier at the beginning
which starts with GI than a pipe and
then the GI number and then a pipe and
then a little code for the source
database for example GenBank in this
case a pipe in the accession what will
happen in the future is that you will
simply have the accession there and
nothing else so the GI is gone the pipes
are gone it's much simpler much more
easy to parse but the GIS aren't present
so that's what you're getting ready for
right is flat files and fast state
records that don't have the GI numbers
present so I'm going to go back to the
slides here and talk a little bit about
what GIS are so just to review what GIS
are and why we've used them so GIS are
integers they point to a particular
version of a sequence record and you
will find them in a variety of databases
so principally an entree Nucor nuke EST
nuke GSS protein and pop set all have
records that are identified with GI
numbers this of course includes the
genbank database in its entirety and the
refseq database in its entirety all of
those records also assign GI numbers and
any of those records on the web have a
report called a revision history which
I'm showing here and revision histories
basically let you look at the history of
the versions of a particular record this
record has an accession DQ 6560 54 but
as you see here its head to GI numbers
in its history because if a sequence
record changes the sequence data the
sequence data itself is updated their
updated and the GI number will shift so
what's happened with this record it came
in in 2006 there was one update that the
GI number didn't change that's because
the update wasn't to the sequence it
could have been to the author list it
could have been to an added publication
it could have been an editorial change
or
annotation but the sequence itself
didn't change but the sequence did
change in August of 2007 when that
changes the GI is updated to a new
number and the version of the accession
is also incremental so now we have DQ
6560 54 dot to second version as opposed
to DQ 6560 54 dot one so you can view
this history for any record in any of
these databases just go to the upper
left you can pull down the menu and get
to the revision history report so the
point about accessions vs. GIS is that
accessions point to a particular version
of a record if you include the version
suffix and the GI points to that same
record so the to a given record a given
version of a record has always had to
identify errs the GI number and the
accession version so the DQ 65 6054 dot
1 points to that particular GI number
the updated record 6560 542 points to a
different GI let's say that in the
future that record is updated again what
would happen could we predict what would
happen from the accession number yes we
can predict because it'll be the same
accession but it will be dot 3 now so
the version increments again but we have
no way of knowing what the GI number
will be effectively it will simply be a
pseudo-random number from a user's point
of view as to what that actual
identifier would be the final point to
make about the accessions versus the GIS
is a bearing session without the version
well what does that refer to it's a
really good question because that
accession number currently actually
points to two different versions in on
tree if you do a search with the bearing
session you'll get the most recent
version at the time of your search but
if you do the search today in six months
later the record is updated to dot three
and you do the search again you'll now
get a different sequence back right so
again accession dog versions are better
to use than accessions because they
point to specific versions just as GIS
do so that's basically where we are in
terms of accession numbers versus GI
numbers why are we changing a number of
reasons one of the reasons is we have
two systems GI numbers and accessions
and that's not as good as having one
consistent system so we're trying to
move to one system of identifier which
would be the accession duck version
sessions versions are more predictable
in other words when they get updated you
know what that's going to be you're
going to increment the version suffix
the accession will stay the same and
they're more human readable I have
strings in them letters at the beginning
that can give you some information about
the type of sequence and we have a lot
more variety of things we can use as
accessions so that's one other reason to
prefer them they're better able to
handle the large variety of sequence
data that we have coming in and the
amount of that data coming in and
another reason why we prefer accessions
that first at this point is that at this
point in time there are already a large
number of sequence records that do not
have gi numbers assigned to them and
never will for example wgs context none
of those have gi numbers tsa context
none of those have gi numbers but all of
them have accessions version so wgs
accession is a long affair it has four
letters at the beginning and then a
series of numbers and the diversion
suffix tsa accessions are very similar
so all of our sequence records
throughout ncbi can be represented
currently with an accession number
version but only a subset by a GI so
that's another reason why we're moving
towards accession versions as the
central and unifying identifiers so what
is the time frame of when all these
things are happening I've mentioned this
a little bit the beginning but just to
crystallize it we had our initial
announcement in March we had a blog post
that came out on our NCBI insights blog
just a few days ago and we're doing a
webinar now we'll continue to do more of
these webinars and more blog posts over
the coming weeks and months as
developments occur with these changes we
are currently continuing to work on many
of the ramifications of these and you'll
hear about these over time so this is
just the beginning of a series of things
that will be letting the community know
about what will be happening with these
in September again GIS will be
disappearing from default
sequence record use of fast day and flat
files the default to use you'll still be
able to we understand right now to have
a downloadable option to get fast day
and flat file use that contain GI
numbers but they won't be default and
finally in March of next year the G eyes
will not be available at all in sequence
record views so what will break right so
what will these changes actually what
caught what consequences will these
changes have to a typical user the main
issue is to think about any process that
you have that parses GI numbers from
flat files or from fast a so if you are
using those data records as a source to
get GI numbers out those processes will
break because the GI numbers will simply
not be there anymore so that's the
that's the primary thing to be concerned
about at this point and again you have
until March to really fix those
processes and update them but that's the
most important thing to think about
things that will not break if you have a
database that has GIS in it now those
GIS will continue to be used as
retrieval engines for or identify errs
for it records in ncbi so any record
that has a GI now will continue to have
that GI will continue to be retrievable
by that GI indefinitely also the GIS
will continue to be in the xml and asn.1
presentations of sequence records so if
you're using the xml of the asn.1
nothing will change just flat files in
fast day however and this is a big
however more and more new sequences will
not be assigned GIS and it's not going
to be predictable which sequences are
going to get you guys in which ones
won't so if you only use GIS the data
that you will be able to access from
NCBI will become more and more obsolete
where you'll get more less and less
newer sequences will actually be able to
be represented in a database that only
uses GIS so again moving to accession
dog version is going to be a plus for
keeping up with the most current data so
our recommendations at this point in
time again any process that parses GIS
from flat files are fast a really must
be
next as soon as possible now preferably
so start working on those those are the
biggest problem any processor database
that depends on GIS all right for
indexing or for retrieval should be
updated to depend on accession version
instead so we're recommending that you
switch those primary keys away from GIS
to obsession versions if you're using
those in some way and that should be
done as soon as you can possibly do it
but again the most critical thing is if
you're parsing GIS out of those flat
files are fascinating all right so
there's a number of things that will be
happening in addition these are not all
to the point that we can tell you
specifically about them but additional
webinars blog posts announcements will
cover these topics but here are some
things that we can generally expect in
the future in September or around
September we expect a new parameter to
be available for the e-utilities and
these are the entree API so the
e-utilities that will allow them to
accept accession version its input and
provide accession version as output so
currently the e-utilities use GI numbers
as their primary keys for retrieval of
sequence data that obviously is not
going to be a great idea moving forward
so we will have an option to switch the
mode in the e-utilities to use accession
dot version instead the GI version will
continue to be the default and will
continue to function for all sequence
records that currently have GIS but to
access all of the data you would need to
use this new parameter to switch the
accession version mode if you will of
the utilities to access data edirect is
a fairly recent package that allows you
to use the e-utilities from the unix
command line this is described in detail
and the utilities documentation I'm not
going to go into that right now but that
will also be updated to handle accession
up version and put an output and that
should be also in a sep tember time
frame we understand that in many cases
what these kinds of changes would mean
is that you will need to convert GIS to
accession versions
we are planning to offer us a new
service again around September that
would be able to do this in large
batches so and by large I mean around a
hundred thousand or more at a time so if
you do have a large set of GIS and just
want to switch them over to accession
version we are going to have a service
available for you to do that in addition
we plan to have some ftp files that
would have the entire set of GIS that
would then associate the corrected
version with that GI those are fairly
large files they be available by ftp
finally in September we expect that a
new version of the blast binaries will
be coming out that will be using
accession about version as opposed to
GIS and we'll have more to say about
blast as events unfold but those are
some things that we're expecting to
happen in the relatively near future
around September so how do you keep
abreast of this how do you keep in the
know tell your friends and neighbors
about things that are happening related
to these changes please follow our blog
that's NCBI insights NCBI inside Scott
you know ncbi nlm nih gov there's links
on our homepage there's links in these
present in these presentation slides the
NCBI news site our social media the
Facebook and Twitter accounts all of
these are again linked from the UCI home
page from the NCBI news page also we
will be announcing all of these changes
on those platforms so that's a great way
of keeping track and keeping up-to-date
of what's happening we will be giving
additional webinars so watch out for
those those will be on the learn page
the URL is right there and if you are
interested in the api's and utilities
it's a great idea to sign up to
utilities announced and the link is
there to where you can sign up to that
mailing list it's just a simple email
list that we do send out all the detail
announcements about upcoming changes to
the utilities there and finally if you
do have questions about this that we
haven't covered today or if you have
questions down the road please feel free
to write to info and NCBI and will
certainly be happy to address those
questions all right so I'm going to take
a break at this point see if there's
questions that we have to address
so we are there's a several questions
basically about the e-utilities there's
a lot of people are concerned about you
know how are they going to work with the
new accession dot version format so can
you address that a little bit what we
expect right now and again this is what
I was talking about in terms of a new
parameter that would be coming out for
the e-utilities is that the parameter at
this point we believe will be called ID
type so ID t ype parameter when it's set
to a value of a cc so you have you added
ID type equals ack parameter to any
utility URL that will convert the e
utility into a mode where it expects to
receive accession versions and where it
will output accession version so a
couple of examples in e search for
example you search typically takes an
entree query into like new core protein
one of those databases and returns to
you a list of GIS all right we don't
want that we want accession versions so
if you were to add ID type equals act
what will happen is you do the same
search using these search the same term
but then what you'll get back in the XML
will be accession about versions rather
than the GI numbers similarly in a fetch
re summary you would be able to provide
accession versions to the ID parameter
now in fetch just as a trick you can do
that now so II fetch does take accession
versions in the ID parameter now and it
has for actually a few years so you can
get that support currently a summary
does not so II summary only takes G is
currently so a summary would be changed
so that if you use ID type equals a key
summary would be able to take accession
about versions and give you back the
docs of XML for those records and then
finally for a link we would expect that
elink would be able to take the
accession versions and then if you're
linking into a database for example
linking from nucleotide to protein or
from genome to protein or from PubMed
nucor the output of the link would be in
accession version rather than G
so those are our expectations that's
being worked on right now and we expect
that to be available publicly sometime
in the sep tember timeframe there are a
few other questions Eric that are sort
of asking about whether they're going to
have fast day files available for
testing with the Deaf lines that are
without the GI numbers in them and also
sort of about like when will people be
expecting fast a files on the ftp site
to change to the new format good
question so in terms of the availability
of test files that is on our agenda to
provide we expect to be able to provide
some sample genbank flat files for
nucleotide and protein as well as fast a
files in the near future so keep abreast
of the announcements and we'll announce
where those are coming I would point you
again if you would like to just take a
look in that news article that I showed
earlier it does have examples of the
places in the flat files and fast day
where the GIS are currently and where
they will not be all right in the new in
the new data format so even though it's
not a full record it would give you a
bit of an idea about what to expect but
we will be putting some sample data out
so that you can test with that in terms
of other presentation formats that are
not directly from entrée for example
like FTP files the GenBank releases
refseq releases the returns that you
would get from the e-utilities these
kinds of questions we expect that all of
these data formats if they're flat files
are fast a well again not have the GI
numbers after march of 2017 so that's
the drop-dead date after that point you
will not see GI numbers in any of the
releases of refseq GenBank any of the
other sequence ftp files that we have
nor any of the returns from the
utilities or entree beginning in
September we will begin to remove the
GIS from default presentations the first
priority with that is going to be on the
web and entree presentations so that's
the first thing would very likely happen
I'm not going to be able to give you a
date right
now about when those changes will happen
in GenBank and refseq releases except
that it will happen by march of 2017 i
think those are the general topics
there's an interesting one that i don't
know the answer to for sure we've
simplified the Deaf line in another way
besides removing just a GI number the
abbreviation for the database and fast a
deafblind has gone away now I assume
that's largely just to make things
simpler although one person in the
question spot is concerned about that
because they find it makes it easier to
understand the future table format yes
thanks for the question it is true that
the current proposal is to remove the gb
or the ref moniker there that would let
you know what the source database was at
this point one of the driving forces for
the simplification is many other
third-party software applications and
other processes except a very simple
deft line with a one identifier more
easily that's one of the things that
we're trying to respond to but I'll take
that under advisement if there's
interest in having you know some
indication about the source database
that has come up in some discussions one
thing I would say is that in many cases
you can determine from the accession
number format what the source database
is so the presence of an underscore in
the accession is a dead ringer that's a
refseq and that's pretty much a
universal rule without underscores it's
almost certainly going to be an I nSDC
sequence genbank e and b LD BBJ you can
also determine TSA wgs sequences by the
fact that there are 4 Alpha characters
in the beginning of the accession so
there are some rules that you can use it
may be that we want to publicize those
and tabulate those a little bit more
clearly so that people can see those and
use them to determine sources all right
well I'll thank everyone for your
attention and for attending today and
again please write to us if you have
additional questions in the meantime
thank you very much
you